Derek Carr played at a high level I'm
very happy with our car what I've told
everybody I've been in touch with since
the day I took this job is we're going
to evaluate every position every year
and if we can get better we will and I
guys get tired of me saying that but
that's really what I told Mark Davis
before I took the job and that that's my
mantra I know one guy who gets tired of
him saying and that's Derek Carr I under
if Derek Carr has blocked mike Mayock on
twitter but that's a different topic
altogether if you are Derek Carr would
you rather because obviously that's the
game we're gonna play for the next seven
or eight minutes
would you rather know right now that the
Raiders aren't behind you or would you
go into next season with another
quarterback looking over your shoulder
I'd rather go into the next season with
another quarterback looking over my
shoulder because then I still have a
little bit of belief like listen that
signing that's signing or that
quarterback over my shoulder lets me
know that okay there might be a little
concern but you know it would also let
me believe okay at least maybe they're
still behind me and then still I got to
go out in the field and prove it anyways
you know you let if you know right now
that like Mayock and a Gruden aren't
behind you
that could have affect everything as far
as how you treat the offseason and how
you do play so I guess I'd rather go
into the the season with a QB looking
over my shoulder yeah I agree with you I
mean look I I don't know that they're
not behind him I just think that they
recognize that at some point there's
going to be an opportunity to upgrade
and they haven't found it yet what's the
old song if you can't be with the one
you love love the one you're with you
wonder with and the moment they can be
with the one they love it's bye-bye
Derek Carr so whether that's this year
or next year it feels like it's coming
the idea that Derek Carr is going to
take every snap that he wants to take
with the Raiders for as long as he wants
to is not only naive it's incorrect he
doesn't understand how the football
business works and I think that's what
got him to block me last year when I
said that Chris when he said I'm gonna
be here as long as I want to be and I
said Derek you don't understand how
football works I think that's when he
blocked me but it's true they don't
decide the players don't decide the
team's decide only the best of the best
players dictate the terms of their
it's always the team looking for the
next best guy whoever it may be and you
have to know when to rip the name off
the back of the jersey and make your
decisions and move on all right we need
to move on okay if you're Tom Brady
would you rather that the Patriots
convince offensive line coach Dante scar
Nekia to stay or that they convince
tight end Rob Gronkowski to come out of
retirement well these are two legends I
mean these are like call a Fame type
names here I think have you given me a
choice though I'm going Gronkowski I'd
rather have him back as much as Donte
score Nekia is awesome you know the
years he retired
you know the Patriots didn't fall off
earth they might have not been as good
on the offensive line but they were
still in AFC championship games and I
think maybe even one year they might
have made it to the Super Bowl I can't
remember what year Dante's went took off
when came back took off again and then
you know it's done now so but I think
Gronk is it just a difference maker as
we know you know Gronk I don't care if
he's not a receiver he is the one of the
greatest mismatches in the history of
football I mean it's what do you do
linebacker safety corner he's got an
advantage on all those guys and that's
where he was amazing for that offense
that you know how to utilize him and
Brady just didn't care if he was
double-teamed or not he'd still throw it
to him yeah look they need somebody who
can command double coverage yeah down
the field yeah a strong case huh yeah
yeah I probably go Gronk Frago Gras
right and really it's better for us if
Gronk comes back of course you know it's
not like it's not like Dante scar neck
he's out there spiking the ball into the
fifth row I mean Gronk is a character
and I'd rather him be in the NFL than
not in the NFL and speaking of Gronk
would you rather see Gronk as a wrestler
in the WWE or see Gronk back on the
field spiking the ball into the fifth
row Chris come on it's not even close
Patriots I want to see him spike in the
ball that's what I want to see that's
what he was put on earth to do that's
why he's famous that's why he's even
being talked about in wrestling hey
whatever WWE respect what you've built
and everything and it's a great
enterprise it certainly has a following
I just I'm not watching sorry I don't
care if Kronk's on there or not I'm not
watching yeah I don't think that that
I'm gonna be interested in seeing Gronk
wrestle and I don't know how much he is
gonna is he gonna be jumping off the top
rope is he gonna be the guy who climbs
the top of the cage and and does the I
don't even know the name of that I die
no wrestling terms but I don't know what
they are figure-four leglock suplex ooh
blouse forever right
suplex a figure-four leglock let me tell
you I could I could tell you that I
don't know that they use this move
anymore there was a guy when I was
growing up who was the wrestler who
always tried to get you into the
figure-four leglock the name may have
been for some reason Bobby Valentine is
my is it was it Mike Valentine really
great Greg Valentine greg the hammer'
valentine he would do the figure-four
leglock and my friends and i were like
you know the horsing around and somebody
put somebody in a figure-four leglock
it's real bend your knee all right one
more one more before we break if you
could force only one rule change in 2020
would you rather have a sky judge or
fourth and 15 instead of on sidekicks oh
this one is one I'm a little torn in
between here I still think I'd rather
have the sky judge I'm just not sure
about the fourth and 15 yet I feel like
I got to see it a little bit like I'd
like to see it experimented with in the
preseason just so I can get a feel for
it maybe the the the positives and
negatives that way I don't want to see
it in a regular season game right now
the sky judge I mean hey you've been
pounding this this this project or story
for a long time and I agree with you
with a lot of things being said there
I'd rather see that I think at this
moment than the fourth and 15 onside
kick replacement yeah give me Scott
judge cuz frankly I would rather they
change the entire kickoff to fourth and
15 and because I want there to be that
element of a surprise onside kick and if
you do 4th and 15 is the way you
transfer position after a score right
you punt
instead of kickoff well you do a fake
punt that's your surprise onside kick
and there's all sorts of different
things that could play
for those permutations of fourth and 15
that I just wish that was the way they
put the ball in play or if they're going
to keep the kickoff you got to go with
the XFL electric football kickoff
formation which is the best thing about
the XFL as far as I'm concerned a full
hour pfg live still to come a weird
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports